breaking tonight a faculty member at the
University of North Carolina's Flagship
campus in Chapel Hill fatally shot today
the suspect is now in custody according
to authorities a lockdown at unc's
campus was in effect for about three
hours today senior National
correspondent Rich Edson has the latest
information good evening Rich good
evening Grant well police have just
wrapped up a press conference they say
they have yet to locate the firearm used
in the shooting at around one o'clock
this afternoon the UNC Police Department
sent out an alert warning those on
campus to go inside and avoid Windows
after reports of an armed and dangerous
person that was followed by a massive
police response and University students
evacuating a portion of the campus about
90 minutes later the police department
sent out this photo calling him a person
of interest one that matches an online
profile for a science student police say
they aren't releasing the suspect's name
and note they haven't formally charged
him
we certainly want an opportunity to
interview the suspect if that's possible
and to actually have the suspect in
custody gives us an opportunity to
figure out the why and even the how and
also helps us to uncover a motive and um
and really just why this happened today
why today why at all
UNC police say they sent out all clear
about three hours after the initial
alert bread okay we'll follow it rich
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else